مرحبًا ، مساء الخير ، آسف على الفيديو ،
Alamo ، شرعي تمامًا ، لماذا شريط على
mocha فقط تأثير فيلم asabi
يشمل الهراء في هذه الوظيفة يتطلب
أن تكون قادرًا على العمل واقفًا في
معظم الأوقات أو طوال الوقت
على قدميك باستمرار
الانحناء باستمرار  ممارسة
مستوى عالٍ من القدرة على التحمل ، حسنًا ،
إذا كان لديك حياة ، فسنطلب منك
نوعًا من منح تلك الحياة أه لا إجازات
في الواقع ، عيد الشكر ، رأس
السنة الميلادية والعطلات ، فإن
عبء العمل سيرتفع ، وهو منصب سيدفعه
تمامًا  لا شيء
يعذرني جيدًا يمكنني أن أتزوج مقدمًا بينما
كان الإيطالي هو المعالج ،
وهذا أمر قاسي تقريبًا ، إنها
مزحة ملتوية للغاية تقريبًا ولكن عندما يكون هناك
وقت للنوم أو لا وقت للنوم ، لا يوجد
موت غير إنساني ماذا لو أخبرتك أن
هناك شخصًا ما
يشغل حاليًا هذا المنصب الآن
بلايين الأشخاص الذين أمهات
أمهات رائعون ويلبيون كل
المتطلبات ، أليس كذلك يا إلهي ، أمي
رائعة ، إنها رائعة  رائع لك